alright back in this country the
coronavirus and the federal government's
response dominated last night's
presidential debate former Vice
President Joe Biden and senator Bernie
Sanders stood at a noticeably safe
distance from one another about six feet
as they argued about why they would be
the best person to lead the country in a
crisis
it'll keep reports from Washington this
is bigger than any one of us in their
first one-on-one debate Joe Biden and
Bernie Sanders agreed they would respond
to the coronavirus better than President
Trump and see his undermining the
doctors and the scientists who were
trying to help the American people it is
unacceptable for him to be blabbering
with unfactual information which is
confusing the general public but they
disagreed about whether a government-run
health care plan should be part of the
solutions you have a single-payer system
in Italy it doesn't work there one of
the reasons that we are unprepared and
have been unprepared is we don't have a
system we got thousands of private
insurance plans that is not a system
that is prepared to provide health care
to all people that has nothing to do
when you're in a national crisis the
national crisis says we're responding
it's all free you don't have to pay for
a thing that has nothing to do with
whether or not you have an insurance
policy both in their late 70s the
candidates were asked what they're doing
to stay healthy I am very careful about
the people I am interacting with I'm
using a lot of soap and hand sanitizers
I do not shake hands any longer I do not
engage and we did we didn't we did the
same thing our staff is all working from
home we're not doing rallies any longer
and on the topic of a vice-presidential
fix sandal said he would like to pick a
woman while Biden made a firm commitment
there are a number of women who are
qualified to be president tomorrow I
would pick a woman to be my vice
president at ok CBS News Washington
made news it was very civilized
conversation